joe biden rejects european pleas to
extend the august 31st evacuation
deadline instead bowing before the
taliban and the white house tries to
spin the situation as a gigantic win i'm
ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let big tech track what you do
anonymize your web browsing
expressvpn.com slash ben we'll get to
all the news in just one moment first
you may have noticed that uh inflation
is just ranging out of control because
of course it is that's the way this goes
these days well here is the thing in the
recent budget proposal the white house
budget office forecast inflation for
2021 at 2.1 percent in june the actual
inflation rate was 5.4
well this would be a really good time to
think about diversifying your assets and
insuring yourself against government-led
inflation do not stick your head in the
sand hedge your savings against
inflation by diversifying into gold and
silver with my friends over at birch
gold group if you haven't reached out to
birch gold to diversify part of your ira
or 401k into a precious metals ira do it
today text ben to 474747 get a free
information kit on protecting your
savings with gold i buy my gold from
birch gold they have an a plus rating
with the better business bureau
countless five star reviews thousands of
happy customers talk to them have them
help you safeguard your retirement
savings text ben 247 4747 to claim your
free no obligation info kit and to speak
with a precious metals expert on holding
gold and silver in a tax sheltered
account again text ben to 474747 protect
your savings today ask all your
questions get all your answers and then
think seriously about diversifying into
gold and silver with my friends at birch
by texting ben 247 47 47. alrighty so
the latest is that joe biden has now
resisted pleas from our allies to extend
the withdrawal deadline of august 31st
now remember it was joe biden who
originally set that deadline of august
31st joe biden came in he said august
31st is the day that we are going to get
out and then we can celebrate the end of
the afghanistan war by september 11th
and then the taliban took him up on that
and they said okay well if you mean
august 31st then august 31st it shall be
and now the taliban is refusing to move
off of that date despite the fact that
they've taken over kabul and are
apparently obstructing efforts to get
people out of kabul so the european
allies the g7
they met with joe biden yesterday and
apparently they were telling him we need
you to give us more time right we have
people on the ground there we need
american troops on the ground beyond
august 31st so we can get our people out
and joe biden said no he said that
staying brings quote added risk to our
troops with increasing threats from isis
well you know what would have been
really nice at this point if you think
about it what would have been awesome is
if let's say we had you know a skeleton
crew like 2 500 troops with bagram air
base under our control and let's say
that we had an afghan national army
capable of beating back the taliban
because they had close air support from
the united states as well as civilian
contractors on the ground holding the
major cities in afghanistan so that we
could work on evacuating people if they
wanted to get out and let's say that we
had had that like um you know three
months ago
oh yes indeed we did and then joe biden
decided you know it'd be a great idea
what if we just take out all the
soldiers and leave everything else
behind and then shockingly we now have
to put soldiers back in to get everybody
else out and now we're going to do this
a second time we're going to
precipitously withdraw our military
in the middle of an evacuation effort
now joe biden says that the evacuation
effort right the precipitous withdrawal
of the military it makes no difference
says joe biden it's not a big deal
because the people that we're getting
out they're really not helping with the
evacuation yet it's not it's not that
big a deal here is the problem it is a
rather large deal we are already
removing people from on the ground right
now and no matter how many times joe
biden says well you know we can still
remove people here's if we're out by
august 31st we have to start
removing american soldiers from the
ground in kabul today right and we have
we've started removing american soldiers
from the ground in kabul
as people are attempting to get to the
airport
now that's all fun and games
until it comes time for the mass
evacuations to happen and we need more
people on the ground
all of this really all of this springs
from a peculiar ideological failing of
joe biden when it comes to the american
military joe biden believes that leaving
americans behind in kabul
is less important than getting american
soldiers out of kabul that is the basic
calculation that is going on right now
he believes that americans will just
forget about what's going on in kabul
but if americans are left behind which
undoubtedly there will be particularly
outside of kabul because we're right now
we're just talking about the americans
who are in kabul there's still
presumably hundreds or thousands of
americans who are outside of kabul still
in afghanistan who may want to get out
we have no way of getting them out now
his belief is that if he can just brazen
this out for a couple more weeks if he
can just brazen this out to the point
where the vast majority of americans are
out of country the media will turn from
yelling at him to praising him for
ending the war in afghanistan americans
will forget about everything bad that is
happening in afghanistan and it just
won't be on the front pages anymore and
everything will go back to normal except
he'll get credit for ending the
afghanistan war that is joe biden's main
calculation americans won't care about
the midterm or long-term strategic
consequences of pulling out of
afghanistan already that's been pushed
into the background
the acute crisis on the ground in kabul
has made people already forget and
really not care very much about the fact
that china is sweeping in that russia is
very eager for the united states to
leave afghanistan that iran is very
eager about all of this that the united
states just lost its air bases not just
in afghanistan but also in pakistan
right
the american people like are not even
thinking about that stuff right now
they're just thinking about the acute
crisis so biden's belief is if we can
just get past this acute crisis if we
mostly solve the acute crisis most
people will leave us alone and my
approval ratings will start to go back
up again he's now down to 41
in the approval ratings what he can't
have however in his own political
calculation is attacks on american
troops by isis
which is again a very bizarre
calculation because american soldiers
are there to repel attacks from
terrorists to protect american citizens
joe biden's logic however is if we have
to leave american citizens there to
prevent attacks from isis on american
troops we will do that that is the
precise reverse of what the american
military exists to do the american
military exists to break things and kill
people in defense of americans joe
biden's belief is that americans should
continue to be in danger american
civilians should continue to be in
danger so we can protect american troops
that's not the way any of this works
civilians are not there to protect the
military the military is there to
protect civilians and if you ask anyone
serving in the military they agree with
this
this is not an anti-military point this
is a definitional point if you ask
anyone in the military what is your job
they would say my job is to protect
americans
joe biden believes that apparently the
americans who are stuck on the ground in
kabul are less important than getting
the troops out because isis might attack
the american troops at kabul airport
again that is only happening as a direct
result of joe biden withdrawing
what military we had from afghanistan in
the first place and also destroying the
afghan military from the inside remember
the entire afghan military had been
built along the lines of working with
the american military in terms of being
able to call in close air support and
use both the american air force as well
as the naked afghan air force which
required american upkeep joe biden
withdrew all of that and so the forces
just dissolved
trobiden's original plan as of july was
that the us would leave the afghan
national army would would probably hold
for another few months and then it would
probably collapse and then he would say
well it's going to happen anyway but it
didn't happen that way as soon as the
u.s withdrew the entire thing collapsed
and now you've got americans trapped and
joe biden's highest priority is not
getting the americans who are on the
ground in kabul out it is getting the
soldiers out because he's afraid
for two reasons one if there's an attack
on american troops the american troops
are gonna have to fire back and then
we're gonna have to put real troop
numbers back on the ground in kabul and
the war that he was so eager about
withdrawing from will have now been
heightened to its greatest point since
and will have no foothold in the country
right so that is his great fear is that
we get drawn back into the war because
he's such a and because he created
this situation himself that is fear
number one is there will be attack on
american troops
the the second fear that he has is that
the protraction of the conflict will
lead to political consequences so what
is the conflict itself and what is the
timeline of the conflict he is hoping
this whole thing is over by september
11th and then he can go back to watching
matlock and spooning cream of wheat into
his adult mouth and that that is his
that is his greatest and most ardent
desire and all they have to do to get
there is just keep lying to you and keep
fibbing to you and keep hoping that you
stop paying attention and instead you
pay attention to their budget deals and
instead you pay attention to kovid it's
it's wag the everything else in order to
distract from what's going on in
afghanistan
and again the baseline for success is
now set so low in afghanistan that if we
get out the majority of the americans
who are on the ground joe biden is going
to call it a success
if we get out the vast majority of the
americans we're on the ground leave a
few behind but we get everybody else out
he's going to call that a success and
say well it was always gonna go this way
he's already saying this like right now
they're already calling it a huge
success and saying it was already gonna
go this way even though it was not
destined to go this way this is a joe
biden decision pure and simple and even
though it is certainly not a huge
success the whole point for example of
the evacuation of dunkirk was to
preserve the british army to fight the
nazis afterward
it is not called a success when you
retreat in the face of a eighth century
goat-hurting barbarian army
for no reason other than your own vanity
which is what joe biden did right here
so here's the latest from the new york
times president biden said tuesday the
us intended to withdraw completely from
afghanistan at the end of the month as
planned rebuffing pleas from britain
france and other nato allies to keep
troops in kabul and hastening the end of
a frantic evacuation that has become a
grim quota to two decades of war again
even the way the new york times phrases
this a grim coda to two decades of war
the united states had lost zero troops
in combat since february of 2020
the main american effort in the war
ended in 2014.
all media coverage was directed toward
the idea that it was a it was a
bare-bones necessity for the united
states to get out of afghanistan
completely that is not true and by
polling data by the way the polls
suggest that americans want it out of
afghanistan but if you said to americans
should we leave like a skeleton force in
there in a non-combat facility to advise
the afghan military
most americans are like okay because we
do that everywhere we have american
troops all over the world we have
american troops in probably over 100
countries at this point
even as mr biden spoke from the white
house officials said the united states
had already begun to reduce its military
presence at hamid karzai international
airport in kabul
sending about 300 of the 5800 marines
and soldiers home in anticipation of the
conclusion of their rescue mission
within a week
the sooner we can finish the better said
the president hours after informing
world leaders of his intentions during
an emergency virtual meeting citing the
threat from isis k which is like special
k except with islamic terrorists and
operating in afghanistan he said every
day we're on the ground is another day
we know that isis k is seeking to target
the airport attack both u.s and allied
forces and innocent civilians yeah it
would be great if we had like a military
presence that could kill those bastards
wouldn't it
yeah i wonder where that
went biden didn't close the door to
extending what has become an immense
evacuation effort he said he has
contingency plans but um i i don't trust
him on that because he said this was all
planned in the first place remember it
was all part of the plan joe biden has
now taken on the full heath ledger in
the dark knight perspective of the joker
which is nobody panics if you have a
plan okay well there's no plan
you're just saying there's a plan and we
all know this we all know this
so the troop drawdown has begun
according to stars and stripes
the the president stuck to his deadline
on tuesday
his decision came as the taliban warning
would not accept a deadline extension
that's the real reason it's not because
joe biden thinks we're going to be done
by august 31st he knows we're not going
to be done by august 31st you can't find
a single person in an intelligence or a
defense position who believes that
everyone who needs to be evacuated will
be evacuated by august 31st they do not
exist okay this is across the aisle
there is bipartisan agreement
across the aisle but this will not be
done by august 31st what is the real
reason that august 31st is the date
because the taliban again a bunch of
barbarian goat herders from the 8th
century
are telling joe biden the president of
the most powerful military force in the
history of the world what to do that is
how craven and pathetic and buffoonish
this president is when it comes to
foreign policy
i mean that's unbelievable the taliban
the taliban are saying you guys better
leave by august 31st
now the normal american response would
be or what
or what we have overwhelming air power
with the most powerful military on
planet earth and if you touch us we will
we will
bomb you forward into the stone age
if you if you touch us we still you have
no air force we will still go in and we
will kill so many of you it will make
your head swim and then you can talk all
you want about how you took over the
country you're gonna have a lot of
bodies to bury so you're gonna let us do
what we need to do or we're not leaving
right we could do that but joe biden is
so scared of the bad headline of having
to actually bomb the taliban his new
peace partners that he is now running pr
for the taliban he is now enthralled to
the taliban he is bowing before the
taliban he works for them this is
unbelievable
a bunch of theocratic
fascistic islamofascists telling the
president of the united states what to
do with americans stuck in kabul and
he's like well
all right
it's the most humiliating garbage i've
ever seen from an american president
we've seen some pretty humiliating
garbage from the american president
ranging from
the president having interns on their
knees in the oval office to january 6.
we've seen pretty bad stuff from
american presidents in the course of my
lifetime let me just say that this makes
all of this looking nothing like nothing
the president of the united states
playing pr spokesperson for the taliban
remember this is the group that housed
the people who committed september 11th
killing 3000 american citizens refused
to turn over osama bin laden
these are the exact same people okay it
is not a different group mala omar's son
is on the taliban ruling council the
head of the haqqani network which is an
al qaeda offshoot is on the taliban
council and currently running security
in
kabul the co-founder of the taliban with
mela omar is now back in power it's the
exact same human beings and joe biden is
not just taking their their
statements under advisement he's just
listening to them
so how many americans are still left
over there apparently the the pentagon
finally announced how many americans
were out now you remember as of last
week it was like 2 200 americans were
out
and we kept saying over and over members
of the press say how many americans are
out how many americans are out people
kept asking because the biden
administration was just giving overall
evacuation figures right they were
loading a lot of afghans onto planes and
then they were saying it's thirty
thousand forty thousand fifty thousand
seventy thousand
and americans are saying okay right but
how many of those are americans because
we've been told there are ten to fifteen
thousand americans on the ground in
kabul alone forget about the rest of the
country yesterday
the pentagon said that there were some 4
000 american passport holders and their
families who had been evacuated
so if you just do the math you're still
talking about what less than a third of
the americans in kabul who have been
evacuated at this point
hey our allies of course are absolutely
enraged that that is no shock and i'll
get to that in just one second first
let us talk about a simple fact when
you're driving around in your car
a lot of people get carsick my wife
tends to suffer pretty severe car
sickness my sister as well and let me
tell you that the best solution to this
is relief band relief ben is the number
one fda cleared anti-nausea wristband it
has been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness anxiety migraines hangovers
morning sickness chemo and so much more
the product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy
provides all-natural relief with zero
side effects for as long as needed it's
almost like a magical it really is
almost magical it's really cool you wear
this this wristband goes around your
wrist it has technology within it and
then because it presses on particular
nerves that have an effect on nausea it
reduces your nausea
relief and works by stimulating that
nerve in your wrist it travels to the
part of the brain that controls nausea
and then blocks the signal the brain is
sending to the stomach telling you you
are sick relief band is the only
over-the-counter wearable device that
has been used in hospitals and oncology
clinics to treat nausea and vomiting so
if you know somebody who deals with
nausea anyway relief band makes a great
gift as i say we've used it in my house
my wife gets carsick no longer not with
relief band as the world is opening back
up don't let fear of nausea keep you on
the sidelines right now relief end has
an exclusive offer just for ben shapiro
listeners go to reliefband.com use promo
code shapiro you will receive 20 off
plus free shipping no questions asked
30-day money-back guarantee
head on over to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com use our promo
code shapiro for 20 off plus free
shipping so our european allies who
still have people on the ground
they say that they are just outraged
like beyond belief they say that this is
the lowest point in u.s british
relations since the suez canal crisis of
1956 and this is called the special
relationship into serious question
according to the uk guardian britain's
evacuation from kabul is now expected to
end within 24 to 36 hours potentially
abandoning thousands of afghans
according to defense sources
the u.s president rejected pleas from
the uk for the humanitarian airlift to
continue beyond august 31st
and this triggered claims from
conservative mps the quote special
relationship is over and the us uk
relations were about to enter their
lowest point since suez
after the g7 uk defense sources told the
guardian the us military is believed to
need two to three days to close down its
operations at kabul airport british
troops want to be at least 24 hours
ahead of that that means that basically
everything has to start wrapping up
within 24 hours of now
right because if you're talking about
august 31st today is august 25th that
means we have six days to get out and we
need at least three days for the united
states to get its military out
so that means that by august 28th pretty
much all the evacuation has to be done
good luck good luck
meanwhile boris johnson focused on what
he called a road map for future
engagement with the taliban
so now we're going to see the europeans
pretend that their their economic impact
on the taliban is going to get them to
stop acting like barbarians okay so
here's the president of the united
states attempting to qual
all of the all of the
qualms of the american public and the
american public are very upset about
this his approval rating is down to 41
percent and this daughtering old fool is
leading us here he was yesterday saying
that we are on pace to finish by august
31st however that deadline relies on our
good friends the taliban to help us
we are currently on a pace to finish by
august the 31st
the sooner we can finish the better
each day of operations brings added risk
to our troops
but
the completion by august 31st depends
upon the taliban continuing to cooperate
and allow access to the airport for
those who were transport transporting
out and no disruptions to our operations
[Music]
oh so it'll it'll it'll go great by
august 31st all it requires is for the
taliban to be our best friends
that's totally gonna happen guys by the
way there's only one way that actually
happens and that is if we are signing
unbelievable ungodly amounts of money
over to the worst force on planet earth
now is that really going to happen
pretty much everybody says no
there are two representatives seth
moulton democrat of massachusetts and
peter major from michigan republican and
they secretly traveled into kabul the
government is trying to push back on
this by saying it was selfish of them to
go to kabul okay first of all they
hitched a flight without the government
knowing about it they didn't hit your
flight back until they found a plane
that had empty seats on it okay but they
released a statement and this is why the
government's really mad this is why the
white house is pissed because these two
congressmen went there to survey the
situation on the ground
and here is what they said
as members of congress we have a duty to
provide oversight on the executive
branch there is no place in the world
right now where oversight matters more
we conducted this visit in secret
speaking about it only after our
departure to minimize the risk and
disruption to the people on the ground
and because we were there to gather
information not to grandstand we left on
a plane with empty seats seated in crew
only seats to ensure nobody who needed a
seat would lose one because of our
presence
washington should be ashamed of the
position we put our service members in
these men and women have been run ragged
and are still running strong their
empathy and dedication to duty are truly
inspiring the acts of heroism and
selflessness we witnessed at hamid
karzai international airport make
america proud we came into this visit
wanting like most veterans to push the
president to extend the august 31st
deadline after talking with the
commanders on the ground and seeing the
situation here it is obvious that
because we started the evacuation so
late no matter what we do we will not
get everyone out on time even by
september 11th forget august 31st
september 11th
sadly and frustratingly getting our
people out depends on maintaining the
current bizarre relationship with the
taliban that is according to
a member of congress and democrats have
moulton and a republican member of
congress peter major but joe biden says
don't worry we're on pace to finish by
august 31st all we need is the help of
the taliban then biden went on he said
we're making contingency plans if
necessary oh really
have those gone so far your contingency
plans
i believe him i believe him here's joe
biden lying to you
in addition
i've asked the pentagon and the state
department for contingency plans to
adjust the timetable should that become
necessary
i'm determined to ensure
that we complete our mission this
mission
i'm also mindful of the increasing risks
that i've been i've been uh
briefed on
and the need to factor those re those
risks in
they're real and significant challenges
that we also have to take into
consideration
[Music]
okay then
joe biden was going to be asked
questions by the press
and so joe biden now treats the press
the same way he treats the taliban he
runs away from them this is the very end
of his press conference he makes a
five-minute statement
something like five hours late and then
he just runs from the room
and this is biden's back better you can
see his body you can see his back better
as he walks away from the podium not
answering any
how many images of the president running
away from the press are we going to need
to see before people start to realize
this guy's a joke i mean like fully a
joke
there's always talk about donald trump's
bad relations with the press
you think donald trump would have been
able to get away with it with the press
if this disaster had occurred on his
watch and then he had run away from the
press every single day like made a
statement and then run headlong from the
press
the problem for republicans is trump
wanted to speak to the press too much
joe biden can't help running away from
the press his handlers do not want him
out front he is disquieting he makes the
world worse every time he opens his
mouth on matters like this
and that is perfectly obvious to
everyone and he is also lying okay the
notion that we're getting everybody out
by august 31st is a lie the the white
house is already moving the bar the
white house is already admitting that
none of the there's no question that
we're going to be leaving afghan allies
who we promised help joe biden said last
month we're going to get them out we're
going to leave them on the ground and
many of them are going to die there's no
question that's happening but there's
open question right now whether we even
get all the americans out
in fact pretty much everybody agrees
there is no opportunity for us to do so
so for example
we are now in the we are now in the
bizarre position in which adam schiff is
telling us more truth than the white
house which is weird because adam schiff
is terrible adam shift the congressman
from california yesterday he said it's
very unlikely we can evacuate everybody
by the end of the month he said this
after going to a classified briefing
i think it's possible but i think it's
very unlikely
given the number of americans who still
need to be evacuated
the number of
sivs the number of others
who are
members of the the afghan press civil
society leaders women leaders
it's hard for me me to imagine all of
that can be accomplished between now and
the end of the month
okay so that's adam chef hey would you
like more democrats saying the same
thing here's representative tom
malinowski saying this deadline is a
mistake
the conditions have changed for the
worst in the last 24 hours uh the
taliban
because of the mistake i think that we
made of setting this artificial
self-imposed deadline they've now seized
upon it as you as you said and started
blocking afghans at risk from going to
the airport
[Music]
representative andy kim another democrat
he says yeah there's no way we're going
to finish this on time
this effort is one that has certainly
led me to believe that that the mission
is not something that we can accomplish
by the end of this month and i strongly
urgently urge the president to
reconsider uh his uh continued uh aim
towards august 31st to be able to get
our mission done we will not be able to
get our mission done by that time based
off of what i've seen and based off of
what we've experienced so far
these are all democrats here's obama's
department of homeland security
secretary jay johnson saying yeah the
airport's going to get a lot worse
before it gets better
i believe that the situation at the
airport is going to get a lot worse
before it gets better this is a country
of 38 million people
we've got to deal with the amp the
american citizens those who qualify for
special
immigrant visas but then those who will
also qualify for refugee status under
our laws and that population can
snowball
how bad is the situation over there
right now pretty damn bad richard engel
from nbc news tweeted out the state
department is in such utter complete
masterful control of the situation that
yesterday they issued a last alert for
u.s citizens to leave afghanistan or
said they were on their own and then
30 minutes later said oh yeah oops no no
we're still here oops
i'm sure americans are stuck in
afghanistan feel
very
i would say sanguine about their
prospects right now probably everything
is fine
meanwhile the new york times reporting
that there are people who are showing up
to the airport and then being turned
away despite the fact that they have
papers
i mean there's there's a story from the
new york times that a former cia officer
had helped
bring something like 500 translators to
the airport and um
they were and they were immediately
rejected
on sunday
there was a matt zeller the former cia
officer who you've heard talk on cnn
he said that uh veterans and contacts in
afghanistan organized an operation to
bring to the airport some 500
siv
the holders who are these this is a
special visa holders who were considered
at high risk of taliban reprisals they
were able to get the afghans inside the
airport then they were turned back at
what he described as a state department
checkpoint
on monday evening according to zeller
taliban soldiers approached the afghans
outside the airport gate and separated
them according to their paperwork
telling visa holders they would not be
allowed to enter
fearing the opportunities to get their
colleagues safely out of afghanistan
were tightening the veterans worked on
evacuation from afar describing feelings
of helplessness
i feel a moral obligation to get these
people outside trip adams an army
veteran who's been working on the effort
when you're halfway across the world and
you can't do anything when hardened
warriors are calling me and they're
cracking this is going to destroy a
generation of veterans
in kabul afghans who worked for the us
government and secured special immigrant
visas said they had received emails from
the state department asking them to come
to the airport and then they get there
and then they're turned back
it's a complete and utter cluster f
it's a disaster area
meanwhile of course the kinder and
gentler taliban are beating women's
death for not cooking
according to hot air in the space of a
single week reliable news coverage from
any part of afghanistan other than kabul
has been becoming increasingly hard to
come by as the taliban solidifies their
control of the nation says jazz jaw of
hot air there are still some media
outlets with boots on the ground out in
the more remote provinces one story was
picked up by cnn earlier this week
telling a tale that took place earlier
in the month before the taliban captured
the capital the incident was reported in
faryab province well to the north it was
one of the earlier province provinces
the taliban retook a woman
pseudonymously identified as nagiya and
her daughter manisha had been visited
for three nights in a row by groups of
more than a dozen taliban fighters they
demanded nashiya cooked dinner for them
quickly running out of food for her own
family she protested she was too poor to
continue to host them so they beat her
to death
she has daughter manisha 25 knew they
were coming her mother had told her
they'd done the same thing the previous
three days demanding she cooked food for
up to 15 fighters
my mother told them i'm poor how can i
cook for you indonesia the taliban
started beating her my mother collapsed
they hit her with their guns ak-47s
meneza said she yelled at the fighters
to stop they paused for a moment before
they threw a grenade into the next room
and fleeing is the flame spread the
mother of four died from the beating
nachos village was overrun by the
taliban so quickly some women reported
not having time to go shop for a burqa
some of them reported being severely
beaten in the streets for them not being
properly attired
good thing that the united states sent
gender advisers to the country now that
that
that definitely worked
also taliban spoke people who say that
women have rights in afghanistan they do
they have just in compliance with sharia
law but they have rights a taliban
spokesperson is now urging women to stay
home because the fighters you know
while we want to be tolerant the
fighters have not been trained to
respect women
the spokesperson zabihullah mujahid
called it a temporary policy intended to
protect women until the taliban could
ensure their safety
he said we're worried our forces were
new and have not yet been trained very
well may mistreat women we don't want
our forces god forbid to harm or harass
women yeah if there's one thing the
taliban is for it's it's for protecting
women protecting the status of women it
is no wonder that there is video now
emerging from afghanistan of afghan men
who have worked with the us military
yelling at joe biden this is not a shock
nor is it unjustified here is one such
video
mr biden you did this you planned this
you made the deal with the taliban this
is the consequences of it this is the
repercussions of it mr biden it's your
end calculation
you are against trump now we are against
you
go to hell by then
unbelievable unbelievable okay well the
good news is it's all everything's going
great
so the goal here and this has been a
typical habit of the abundant
administration is you
say that you set the goal post really
really close so then if you overcome the
goal post you say that you've done an
amazing job so you remember that the
bright administration did this for
example with the coveted vaccine roll
out they said
if we get to a million shots a day we
are so good at our job by the time they
took office we were already doing a
million shots today and then they're
like oh man look how good we are at this
we're doing a million shots a day
so they do this sort of stuff routinely
or they set the bar really really low
like so low that
michael moore could jump it easily right
it's like the lowest bar in the entire
world
all the forces of gravity could not
prevent them from overcoming this tiny
tiny little bar right well that is what
they are now doing with afghanistan so
they completely gave up a country of 38
million people 19 million of whom are
women who will be forced into uh who
will be routinely raped for the rest of
their lives many large philosophers
not only that they're leaving thousands
of americans right now without a way to
get out in
kabul but there are flights leaving
kabul airport
so that means that everything is going
great
in fact says gensaki this is the this is
a massive success what you are watching
on the ground as afghans plummet from
3000 feet down onto the tarmac and
explode as you watch the americans
in in in kabul attempting to get out
being beaten by the taliban
as you watch american soldiers breaking
down because they can't help their
friends who served with them in the
afghan army this is all a massive
success
it's a massive success
some might suggest this is a big lie
some might say that here is here's
jensaki
i would say that this is now on track
peter to be the largest airlift in u.s
history
so and that is
bringing american citizens out it is
bringing our afghan partners out it is
bringing allies out
so no i would not say that is anything
but a success
it's nothing but a success nothing but a
success it's an unbelievable success
see we had this boat and the boat was
okay it was on the wall when the
greatest boat was on the water and we
took some dynamite and we put it below
the water line and then we just exploded
it and now there's water gushing in here
but let me tell you we have lifeboats
and many of those lifeboats will be
filled with passengers not all the
passengers will get out alive some of
them will drown some of them will end up
at the bottom of the sea
don't say this is a disaster this is a
massive success
it's a massive success
never before i mean this is a big boat
it was a big boat and that means that
we're gonna have a lot of lifeboats
filled with people in fact this is the
greatest lifeboat rescue of our lifetime
it is the greatest success in using
lifeboats we have ever seen sure it was
us that we put the dynamite below the
water line and sure we did like the fuse
and sure we did explode it and let the
water start pouring in like poseidon
adventure
but the real thing you need to focus on
is that never before we're setting like
a guinness book of world records for how
many people we are evacuating from a
place we just trashed
i mean look at us we are so good at this
says jensaki
you know how stupid she thinks you are
you yes you and all americans you know
how dumb she thinks you are
none of this had to happen zero of it
zero of it
this is all joe biden's disaster from
top to bottom
and here she is telling you it's massive
success and how dare you think anything
else it doesn't matter so gensake was
then asked at this press conference you
know we're all getting emails from
people saying we're trying to evacuate
people
like i
like on this show like the host of the
show i have gotten emails multiple
from people many many many from people
who have served with afghans on the
ground in afghanistan and want to get
them out and they're asking me how do i
get people i forward them on to some
people who are trying to facilitate
and i like again i'm like three steps
removed from the people who served on
the ground in afghanistan i didn't serve
in the in the army i'm not an officer in
the army i don't work for the state
department i don't work for the
government i'm getting emails and i'm
forwarding them on to people who once
served in the military or know people
who served in the military and those
people in the military are then trying
to get that to the state department
they're trying to work with ngos it's a
disaster area okay well jennifer was
asked about this her answer is uh
shall we say less than satisfying
this is a 24 7 operation embassies all
over the world are supporting phone
banking text spanking and email efforts
if we are not in touch with this
individual give me their contact
information and we will get in touch
with them if any of you are hearing from
american citizens who can't reach us
give me their contact information and we
will get in contact with them
[Music]
okay how you know your dm's open there
jen
how exactly do you think that it's going
to happen
okay then
like it is so obvious what the agenda of
the administration hears it is not to
facilitate success it is to cover their
ass that's what this is about and
covering their ass means covering for
the taliban and pretending that we have
a solid deal with the taliban on the
ground and that everything is going to
be hunky dory by august 31st so start
getting the troops out now well again
their own description is ten to fifteen
thousand americans were on the ground in
kabul their own description yesterday is
that about four thousand americans are
out that leaves behind somewhere between
if my math is correct six thousand and
eleven thousand americans they still
need to get out and that's just in kabul
alone that does not include any of the
outlying areas and there are many
americans out there because remember the
taliban took over the country inside of
like a week
like this is this is madness and it gets
worse i mean gensake
the left is um slobbering over jensaki
and her incredible performance i don't
know what they're watching we'll get to
more of this in just one second first
let us talk about a simple fact if you
are a responsible adult you need life
insurance it is indeed that simple if
you're walking down the street and
suddenly a brick falls from the heavens
and just cracks you across the top of
the head as you lie bleeding out you're
going to think to yourself you know what
would have been a good idea having life
insurance for my family or you could at
least feel better about that because
you'll have life insurance by going to
policy genius policy genius makes it
easy to compare quotes from over a dozen
top insurers all in one place why
compare you could save 50 or more on
life insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius it could save 300 bucks or
more per year on life insurance by using
policy genius to compare policies the
licensed experts at policy genius work
for you not the insurance companies so
you can trust them to help you navigate
every step of the shopping and buying
process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius thousands of five-star reviews
across trustpilot and google and
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirement
for a simple phone call this exclusive
policy was recently rated number one by
forups higher than options from ladder
ethos and bestow getting started is
simple first head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro in minutes you
can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price when you're ready to apply the
policy genius team will handle the
paperwork and the scheduling for free
policy genius doesn't add on extra fees
head on over to policygenius.com shapiro
get started right now policy genius when
it comes to insurance it's nice and very
important to get it right i'll get some
more of this in just one second first on
monday the fda announced approval of the
fisa vaccine which is good what is bad
as the joe biden then decided it was
time to urge private companies to
mandate vaccines for their employees
well now is a good time between that and
uh and president biden
completely botching afghanistan it is a
good time to get together for backstage
there's a lot to talk about me jeremy
boring michael moles matt walsh and
cliven i'm sure there will be some hot
fraught debate it streams tomorrow 7 p.m
eastern 6 p.m central on dailywire.com
or on our youtube channel daily wire do
not miss it
also as you know matt walsh is one of
the most judgmental people on earth
which means he's not big on second
chances especially when it comes to your
sweet baby gang anthem submission today
is your last chance to submit your songs
to be the new sweet baby anthem so if
you want to capitalize on the
opportunity for your song to be heard
around the world this is your last
chance he's looking for an original song
that embodies the exact essence of the
sweet baby gang all submissions should
be in the form of youtube video links
and will be judged american idol style
by me and other daily wire hosts but you
the viewer you will be voting on which
song wins to enter go to dailywire.com
sbg submissions and today august 25th at
midnight so if you think you've got what
it takes to impress matt your time is
running out voting will take place on
labor day tune in to the matt walsh
youtube channel to watch the judging of
the submissions the winner will be
announced september 8th on the matt wall
show and will wear the crown of the
creator of the most important anthem to
ever be anthemed again this is your last
chance remember enter your song into the
competition go to dailywire.com sbg we
all look forward to hearing it also we
have a really big announcement to share
with you today deadline hollywood just
released the details and an exclusive
photo of the daily wire's first original
film it's called shut in it's directed
by dj caruso executive produced by daily
wire co-founders production on the
thriller wrapped this weekend it's going
to be available to you daily wire
members beginning in january 2022 so
that will be the next movie from daily
wire that's we had run hide fight now we
have one called shut in it's excellent
it's really really good it's a tense
thriller the film is centered around a
young single mother who's barricaded
inside a pantry by her violent
ex-boyfriend using nothing but her voice
to guide her two small children to
escape escalating danger it's intense
it's suspenseful and it has the values
you're looking for the trailer for
shut-in will be out soon we know our
members are going to love this film we
need your support by the way because
when we entered the industry we were
sending hollywood a message you no
longer have a monopoly on the film
industry the release of shut-in is the
next step in proving it we need your
support which is why you should go
subscribe and help us out you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so again the the goal of the biden
administration is to just obscure what
is happening in afghanistan long enough
for us to leave and then they hope that
you forget about everything that just
happened we've had some tens of
thousands of afghans who've been
evacuated we still have thousands of
americans on the ground in kabul which
raises the question why aren't those
americans the first ones out
i want the afghans out too and we made
promises to those people those people
spend 20 years fighting wars in cahoots
with the united states they put their
lives on the line for american interest
because yes we have interests in
afghanistan against terrorism which
we're now going to pretend we don't have
for the sake of a dumb talking point but
if you're going to evacuate people and
you're the american government the first
people you should be evacuating are
american citizens so where are they why
can't we get them out why weren't they
the first people out the reason the
pentagon has been spending days
obscuring how many people were americans
on those flights is because the number
is really low again a week ago we had 2
200 americans out today we have 4 000
americans out we've been flying 10 000
american 10 000 people out a day 20 000
people out a day why aren't more
americans out what are the obstacles why
isn't this administration being honest
with us
well gen zaki has one goal and one goal
only and that is to prevent people from
using the word stranded so once again
gensake and peter ducey went over it
when again whether americans are in fact
stranded in kabul
what do you say to the american citizen
in kabul that fox spoke to this morning
her name is she's going by fatima she
says we are stranded at home for four
days three days we didn't hear anything
from anywhere and they're saying to go
to the airport but we're not being given
clear guidance our emails are getting
ignored say no americans are stranded
this is someone in kabul who says i am
stranded so is there a better word for
somebody who can't leave the house to
get to the airport because
jake sullivan says isis is outside the
airport
i would welcome you providing their
phone number and we will reach out to
them today
oh we'll reach out to them and if you
give her their phone number then they'll
reach out you know that's and that's the
important thing right they're not
stranded because gen saki told peter
ducey
who is not a spokesperson or a lawyer
for this woman or this woman herself
that she is on call
well great jen i'm sure that person
finds that super comforting and very
very very helpful by the way jinsaki
also said that as everybody knows when
we say we have to be out by august 31st
that means civilian evacuations have to
end before august 31st because again we
have to get the military out too so here
is jen's hockey admitting as much
does that mean that the evacuations will
stop before the actual 31st so then
there is time to get the troops and
their machinery and weaponry out of
there
that would be correct yes that there
would need to be time to wind down the
presence i will note though that the
purpose of this statement is to provide
additional context of what the president
conveyed to the g7 which includes a
number of very key components as he
assesses day by day
[Music]
oh well you know he's testing it day by
day and if we know one thing is that joe
biden is definitely on top of the news
which is why he has failed to actually
be in concert with the news for weeks on
end and was lying to the american public
or was ignorant of what was actually
going on so if he's on top of it joe
biden is on top of it the same way that
your grandmother in a nursing home is on
top
of the news
sure
okay
all right by the way jen's hockey also
admits there could be americans left in
afghanistan after august 31st this is
saying the quiet part out loud right
here
if one u.s citizen was suddenly
discovered you know saying hey i really
want to get out and i'm stuck who knows
where somewhere in afghanistan or in
kabul
you've got any problem would this
trigger a
diplomatic military
or hands-on deck type thing to get that
person out whatever the date
our commitment continues to be to us
citizens if they want to leave we will
help get them out
of the day
again we expect there could be some uh
but i don't i'm not going to get into it
further go ahead
she's not going to get into it further
there could be americans who are left in
afghanistan we expect there will be
americans left in afghanistan after
august 31st but then we'll be working
back channels to try and get them out
you know none of this had to happen none
of it
how delusional is all of this how much
do you trust this administration
i mean i don't trust this administration
further than i can throw it which is not
very far the taliban have said we are
not allowing people to get to the
airport right the taliban spokesperson
in fact came out and said we are not
going to allow afghans any longer to
exit the country they say change your
policy please don't encourage our
friends to leave don't encourage our
engineers our doctors our military we
need them we are not in favor of
allowing afghans to leave so the taliban
is closing the doors on afghans trying
to get out because they are either going
to conscript them into the taliban or
they're going to murder them
but the good news is gen saki says well
you know we are so we expect the taliban
to let them leave here's shenzhaki
we've seen over the past several of the
past nine days a rush of people attempt
to come to the airport we certainly
understand that but that also creates
security risk and one that we have great
concern about so to be clear individuals
who are eligible for special immigrant
visas or others who we are helping
facilitate their evacuation and their
departure we are in touch with them or
working to be in touch with them about
how and when to come to the airport as
well as american citizens as you well
know and we expect that uh they will be
able to reach the airport
oh we expect it w well and it's not like
the taliban's in control of security
lady
which we all know so politico even
politicos like this is gaslighting
politico has an entire piece today
titled the definition of gaslighting as
chaos unfolds at kabul airport biden
team projects calm
i don't think the president's rhetoric
matches the conditions on the ground one
former state department official said
tens of thousands of afghans awaiting
u.s visas and thousands of american
citizens are still stuck in kabul unable
to find safe passage through frantic
crowds taliban checkpoints and afghan
guards stationed outside the airport
gunfire erupted outside of the north
gate of hamid karzai international
airport on monday killing a number of
afghan security forces american
officials have repeatedly had to close
the gates for extended periods leaving
guards to turn away even u.s passport
holders
multiple sources point to deteriorating
conditions inside the airport including
lack of power and sanitation tension has
emerged between american troops on the
ground and state department officials
trying to extract u.s citizens and
afghan allies meanwhile the west wing is
looking increasingly disconnected from
reality as the biden white house strives
to project a sense of calm competence
even as the taliban tightens their grip
on afghanistan
if you look at what we're doing now and
taking evacuating thousands of people
every day it has been a tremendous piece
of work said defense secretary lloyd
austin on sunday
while the evacuation has significantly
ramped up in recent days says politico
the reality on the ground belies the
narrative the situation is under control
the scenes around kabul airport have
been marked by violence disorganization
bureaucratic infighting and delays
according to video and text exchanges
viewed by politico
the result is an administration that
appears increasingly out of touch as
reports from kabul continue to reflect a
chaotic evacuation i don't think the
president's rhetoric matches the
conditions on the ground says jenna ben
yehuda a 12-year veteran of the bush and
obama state department and president of
the truman center which is trying to
evacuate afghan allies
they keep saying this was inevitable
there is absolutely a way to avoid this
if that's not the definition of
gaslighting i don't know what is said
chris purdy project manager of veterans
for american ideals at human rights
first
in order to speed the evacuation effort
defense officials in recent days
proposed retaking bagram air base
using bagram as an additional location
for flights out of the country would
help ease the backlog at kabul but the
proposal was nixed because the white
house and some pentagon officials
worried it would require deploying a
large number of additional forces and
could spark a conflict with the taliban
it was discussed but was not a good
option said one senior defense official
bagram would have been an airborne
assault just a huge operation would have
looked like a re-invasion you can't look
like a re-invasion guys i mean we're
busy surrendering here i don't know what
you guys are doing but we're
surrendering around here and if if our
surrender gets in the way of americans
leaving successfully well you know
surrender was really important because
joe biden wanted to go to sleep at night
knowing he had surrendered in
afghanistan
and he goes to sleep at like 6 30 at
night so we had to get out of there
right quick
the pentagon has acknowledged conducting
only limited rescue operations within
the city to bring americans into the
airport
but officials are running up against
that august 31st deadline
and i i don't think i've seen it
characterized better than richard engel
of nbc news did last night on nbc news
here he was
this war used to be called operation
enduring freedom and it's turned out not
to be enduring and they're not leaving
behind a society that is free it is only
free according to what the taliban says
it will be pre if the taliban promises
that it will be free so uh you could
also look at this as a tremendously
humiliating
moment of american humiliation
leaving
forced to leave on the taliban's clock
and and with the taliban's good graces
[Music]
that is correct and that is joe biden's
decision there is no one else to blame
for this except the old man who says the
buck stops with him so the american
people have said the buck stops with him
now the question is going to be where we
go from here how many americans get left
behind how many afghans get left behind
and will the american people continue to
pressure the biden administration to do
the right thing and get people out or
are they just going to forget about it
the way that joe biden seems to think
you will maybe he's just projecting his
own short-term memory loss onto the
american people all right we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content in the meantime go check out
the michael knowles show that is
available right now i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crans the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
dr fauci sees his shadow and predicts
another 207 days of lockdown the white
house admits that it will likely strand
americans in afghanistan and big banks
finally do something right check it out
on the michael knowles show
[Music]
you